at various times in my upbringing and in
my career I've had role models that
inspired me there it goes back to my
high school math teacher who inspired me
to think that I could do mathematics and
then in college I had a professor who
was combining psychology and economics
and I thought that's that's really solid
it sounded very real to me and then in
graduate school I had a advisor who
connected me I I thought made my
economic work connected to real problems
in the world and then over the years
I've had others that there are lots of
my wife has been an inspiration to me
too my wife is a psychologist and that
has helped mold my thinking